you can just kind of neutralize ding
with white you'd never want to lose and
wow okay not one e4 this normally would
look like a mouse lip but magnus hasn't
reacted instead playing one e3 and you
nearly never ever see this from a top
chess player on the first move because
white doesn't take center black can now
occupy the center with his pawns magnus
maybe just uh he's done this before we
should mention maybe just waiting to see
how ding reacts and ding smiling that's
really nice from being 1 am in the
morning still smiling and okay just
maybe surprised by magnus's first move
brings his night out also very flexible
yeah magnus does have a track record of
playing these kind of small little moves
i do remember one encounter where he
actually opened with one b3 the uh
cowboy variation as it's kind of
nicknamed and uh yeah well ding reacts
in a very solid way i can also remember
that once he magnus actually mouse
slipped against the maximum bachelor
graft and this time was c3 but this one
was a complete accident yeah i think uh
actually magnus later revealed that that
wasn't a mouse slip so he was just he's
just freestyling he's just playing uh
kind of random first moves to surprise
his opponents and ding was still
slightly smiling on the last turn now
finally does occupy the center with a
pawn for black so
this is
okay now especially after this last move
it's heading towards more well-known
territory uh white did start with that
kind of unambitious looking first move
but now fighting against black central
chain and
black just solidifying his pawn center
there and okay now we are back in a very
very well known position uh that
normally starts from different move
orders normally starts with white maybe
pushing the c pawn first or bringing the
knight out first
and uh here ding is spoiled for choice
i'm expecting to see black's bishop
develop like start square bishop there
we go and uh magnus meanwhile he'll
start pushing pawns he'll be doing
just some developing moves over the next
few times
isn't this your specialty david i have
played didn't we play a game in this
type of thing it wasn't this exact move
i'd move order i played uh the one well
i played the b pawn push first before
bringing my knight out against you i
think but um either way it could
transpose to very well known
uh territory so yeah
here white is just fine tattooing his
bishop you mentioned the kind of cowboy
kind of approach to chess which normally
starts with one b3 and it's transposed
into very similar territory so white
bishop that has just developed it's on a
long diagonal pointing towards the black
king and now after pawn takes pawn if
black recaptures with this pawn on
ivanka we might be heading into
something very similar to what we
discussed
in the game in the british championship
2016. and he did capture with the pawn
so we're expecting magnus actually to
stake a claim in the center and advance
his queen's pawn two squares forward and
uh
he would be following the game
how against house
and i'm laughing because it was a really
bad game by me
i do think these two have seen it
was it at the good night so magnus could
follow
it was in the british championships
and uh well it was it was a game that it
was quite instructive actually because
it's basically it was a kind of a grand
master against international master kind
of scenario where i was running scared
and i started making passive decisions
so if you look at it you'll just see
that i kept simplifying the position and
trading things off and every single
trade that i made
favored david ah but
magnus is the master of trades yeah he
he's not going to be making those trades
you know here there and everywhere he he
does it with intelligence and he does it
knowing which pieces will be benefiting
him in the future
yeah and meanwhile i'm slightly
surprised to see magnus thinking here
because as far as i know there's only
really one logical move and he plays it
so he's now occupying the center with
pawns black there had two strong pawns
you have to stop their advance you have
to challenge as ivanka mentioned a bit
earlier now the black knight coming out
and i'm expecting to see white's
light-squared bishop develop white's
king still stuck in the middle you need
to castle it away to safety as soon as
possible before things really start to
open up
before the action happens so
still relatively standard stuff ding by
the speed of his moves it feels like
he's in his homework he's studied this
before magnus meanwhile slightly
hesitant and especially when they're
very obvious moves and not too much
choice we're not used to seeing uh
seeing him spend 30 seconds one minute
per move normally he's very very quick
until the critical moments in the game
so
maybe magnus just
trying to warm up just trying to get in
the flow but he needs to get that viking
to safety i think he's maybe trying to
psychologically worrying you know just
by pausing thinking you know
is he does he have something up his
sleeve you know keep those options open
but i think magnus is just going to play
the most logical move which is to step
the light square bishop one square um
not two squares just keep it one square
keep the king nice and solid
yep and magnus just head in his hands is
he trying to remember something maybe he
and his coaches for the world
championship match had kind of cooked up
some really interesting new idea there
but magnus in the end playing the most
logical move the most standard move and
ding bringing his knight to the center
of the board this could be heading in
the same direction as actually a game we
saw yesterday
between david anton and duda where duda
very easily as black was able to
neutralize devon anton and get the draw
he needed to progress to the semi-finals
so maybe ding was actually watching
yesterday's games
uh maybe after everything had finished
maybe he was just looking at the games
looking for new opening ideas that's
what the top players do
and uh yeah he's trying to neutralize
magnus by offering those trades we
mentioned just on black's terms bringing
the black knight to the center of the
board
and what will magnus do will he castle
the white king away very logical will he
bring the white rook on the left-hand
side towards the center
i must admit castling looks incredibly
logical um another move that i'm
checking the database that's been played
before is white playing pawn takes pawn
that feels a little bit more risky
because
the king is uncastled and there could be
some trouble
surrounding that white knight sitting on
c3
yeah unless you're 100 sure on the
details you don't want to keep your king
in the center too much longer for
example the black queen could come out
to the left side of the board start
pinning white tonight aiming towards
white's king on the diagonal you just
have to get it to safety and uh yeah
magnus it's very strange to see him
thinking because this is still a
well-known position and he is known for
kind of his vast knowledge of openings
his huge repertoire he can play every
opening under the sun he knows a lot of
small details uh all the kind of nuances
within those openings so to already have
spent four and a half minutes
it's very surprising intriguingly enough
i'm again checking the database i can
see that magnus doesn't have any
recorded games here i mean the highest
rated player is maxine bachelor graph
and
wow magnus actually
taking the risk and calculating
everything out that it is safe to
capture the pawn in the middle
um
a little bit surprising to me because i
thought if you don't necessarily know
the line and you may be trying to wing
it a little bit keep the kings castled
as a safe option but uh here
the real option in the position is
actually to step forward with the dark
squared bishop one square and line it up
towards the knight on c3 yeah so just to
show what's about to happen we might see
some quick moves on the board once ding
just maybe remembers his homework and
comes to terms with the position and
you've actually you want this move
creating a nasty pin actually yeah
one one of one of two moves
and this would force white to defend
this knight you can't actually jump out
the way with your knight now because
black's bishop would pounce and hit this
rook in the corner black would be doing
very well here so you need to guard this
knight that's attacked twice uh you need
to defend it again with the rook and
then black can continue uh fighting
against this knight hitting it now with
the queen the bishop and the knight is
all about this one square the pressure
on the white knight and you need to
block it i think the move here if i
remember correctly is bringing the
knight to the centre of the board and uh
now we would see some exchanges for
example uh ivanka here if i remember
correctly it's knight takes pawn is the
main move
and uh maybe there are others here as
well but either way there's going to be
lots of exchanges white temporarily upon
up but white still with this king stuck
in the middle eyed up by the black queen
on the side so it's just really really
tense and it's surprising to see ding
think actually here um because okay he
does a similar idea just in a different
order instead of bringing his bishop to
create a pin on this diagonal he brings
his queen out first and i think it
should be very similar i think the two
variations might transpose so black's
queen creating this pin as we mentioned
white's rook protecting its knight
yep yeah still would you still think
it could be a draw
you know it's looking like it uh at the
moment it's level that doesn't
necessarily mean draw it just means both
sides have their chances but this is
literally the game that we saw yesterday
between um anton
and and
yeah and that was a quite quick that was
quite a quick draw
that would be great news for ding right
with the black pieces late at night in
in china to start out with a quick draw
and exactly get one game over and always
you know when it's the first game of the
day you feel a little bit nervous you
don't quite know how things are going to
go whether it's going to be a good day
bad day
so just to show how that game went
yesterday so black did indeed capture
the pawn back so it's actually level
material again white's king as we
mentioned is super
uncomfortable just eyed up by the black
queen but first you need to trade a set
of knights if you castle your king away
to safety now we would see knight takes
night and suddenly after the black
knight retreats both sides have isolated
pawns but white's is very weak targeted
by the black knight and by the bishop so
i'm expecting in the current position
magnus to capture these knights trade
these guys off and then castle his king
but this is exactly what we saw
yesterday as mentioned the black knight
now hopped into the center of the board
once again it's all about this piece
putting pressure on this knight and due
to this pin the knight shouldn't move
and actually we're heading in this
direction the white queen now could step
to the side and now lots and lots of
captures on this square everything
coming off the board and uh yesterday we
saw duda get greedy and capture this
pawn and later the game did fizzle out
to the draw so
yeah nothing new under the sun in this
game so far and uh it just feels like
both players a bit uncertain ding more
confident of the two but magnus spending
a lot of time maybe just can't remember
the move orders and uh maybe just trying
to find a way to avoid uh or kind of
change course from that game that we saw
yesterday where black was completely
fine after taking this pawn
so yeah the player's
just psychological battle so far in the
opening yeah
but like you say very odd because magnus
now down to under 10 minutes
and ding barely used any time on the
clock 30 seconds
and uh as you say all been seen before
nothing new under the sun i love that
expression yeah
and i'm just again what is magnus
thinking about the white king is in the
center of the board
i know the top players they like to
break rules occasionally they'd like to
kind of surprise their opponents do
something a bit unexpected
something a bit unconventional but not
too much choice here
uh
maybe you can make an argument for
picking up white's a pawn pushing it
forward one square but that feels really
loose
um i think it's time for magnus okay he
does step his queen up one square so
avoiding the line that we just showed
now black cannot really jump into the
center with his knight or
okay maybe he can uh it's really
complicated position but that white king
while it's in the center not feeling
comfortable it's back to ding now and
lots of choice for him he could move the
black knight he could start developing
the black light squad bishop connecting
the black rooks
and uh yeah it's very tense i think
black already ding solved all his
opening problems he's emerged with a
very healthy position out of the opening
i'm just checking the database i can see
just one game played before between some
very strong players actually it's uh
boris gracieff against uh
kardesefsky i'm not very good with my
russian names sorry is an international
master okay and that game it was a quite
a good victory for white play with the
white pieces
and you mentioned the word
unconventional and i really have to
share with you a quite nice little
selfie because we love it when everyone
at home gets enthusiastic
and the tears on the chest and uh
abhishek is sending us uh a selfie
saying that they're watching with panda
and gator and their favorite sunny
bunnies and look at all of those little
soft toys amazing and
you can always tweet us uh your
questions your thoughts and of course
your selfies using the hashtag
chesschamps and uh another person who's
watching the show is female nurse who's
hoping that this time that they'll be
able to finish another chapter at the
end of today's show yesterday wasn't
such a big success they didn't get past
the first page but uh air things device
telling me that they have good air
quality ooh yeah
very nice
all right well these uh quad final and
semi-final days they are hectic chess
going on almost all the time which uh is
a lot of fun and very dramatic but this
one kind of slow start to the day so far
magnus carlson with the white pieces and
you guys are thinking this could be a
relatively quick draw if but we see
magnus thinking so if he is not able to
come up with something very surprising
yeah and his last move it may not be
objectively the best one for white this
kind of stepping up with the queen but
it does keep the game alive it's not so
easy for black to actually trade off the
queens now because if black does jump
into the center of the board with his
knight again we'll see some exchanges
but maybe in white's favor
so magnus trying to avoid any quick
draws any quick results he just wants to
keep this game alive and he wants to
outplay ding a bit later on in the game
so right now
i mean there's so many tempting moves
for black black's rook next to his king
come across two squares black can bring
his light squad bishop out as i
mentioned i think magnus just wants to
give ding a lot of choice and uh if ding
can't decide then maybe the clock will
take down again and uh magnus will feel
more comfortable if he's not too far
behind
on that clock so yeah he's just keeping
the tension and that's promising for us
we don't want to see quick draws we want
to see life we want to see really
hard-fought hard-fought games and maybe
even some end games so we can learn a
few things yeah and magnus is going for
that
yeah we do want excitement we don't want
to be falling asleep because the reason
i'm saying falling asleep is because
jane has a question for you david
she asks um you've mentioned a few times
that you've fallen asleep playing chess
weren't you afraid that you might
oversleep
and how did you manage to wake up
yeah yeah i shouldn't confess things
live on the show right um there have
been a few occasions the older i get the
more i fall asleep i found um yeah i'm
very scared that i'll just not wake up i
think usually i've woken up when my
parent presses the clock luckily
nowadays with electronic clocks they do
make a sound yeah and uh yeah i guess i
do kind of rest my head in a pose where
it's quite near the clock but yeah i
don't recommend it it's not professional
try and get a full eight hours before
you play a long game um these days i
only tend to fall asleep during these
long time controls um once the european
championships with its seven-hour time
control
yeah and my match against neil's
granddaddy and seven hour time control
it was hard to stay awake sometimes but
you did stay awake during oh you've been
most of the time there was one moment
did you fall asleep
no comment
yeah i don't recommend it i think you
need to have a healthier routine than i
do just to eat healthy sleep healthy and
that really helps on the chest i mean
it's no coincidence that i didn't play
great games when i was falling asleep
okay so there is a correlation here
between falling asleep and your result
definitely okay you have to be fully
focused and these days i think it's
partly because playing isn't my main
thing i do a few other kind of bits and
pieces for work and it's just hard to
kind of plan my routine so i wake up at
the right time every day that the game
itself is the uh it's kind of
the main part of the day
yeah i think these top players because
chess is their main career like playing
uh they are able to focus purely on the
games they don't have any distractions
beforehand any uh kind of anything to
stay up for late at night so yeah
they're very disciplined and that's what
we have discussed uh when it comes to
women in chess right that it's so
important that women as well um are
given the opportunity to focus 100 on
chess that they're not studying on the
side or having a job on the side
because until that happens it's going to
be hard to sort of find the next top 10
player uh as a woman yeah because the
person who's going to break the top 10
level i mean like you say has to be 100
dedicated to the game has to be able to
focus just on the chest
and uh yeah at the minute it's it's
difficult i mean a lot of the female
players are mothers yeah uh they're also
working um in a lot of the top female
country uh women in their countries
actually not earning enough
to be able just to be playing i mean so
so they have to support their living by
teaching writing and it's it's difficult
to fit everything in
and i mean if there's one physical
difference between men and women it
might be in the endurance i don't know
how significant it is but because men
traditionally are stronger and they're
physically yeah they can actually play
for a lot longer
and
maybe maybe this has an impact as well
when it comes to those seven hours yeah
but you know again if you're able to fit
in
like like i know alexandra castano her
main strength is that she's very
powerful she's very very fit she runs
marathons and often she's able to win a
lot of games in that seventh hour
so
yeah i mean you just have to be able to
like many sports and everything you just
have to be able to dedicate yourself
fully to every aspect of the game so
that's endurance that's
mental dexterity and of course uh being
in psychological tip-top shape
absolutely yeah
all right we do have a move is uh
ding also trying to fight on it in this
game he's definitely trying to create
something and he's added maximum
pressure against the white pieces um
there's a lot of tension right now so
black's bishop has just come to the edge
of the board it's offering a trade of
light-squared bishops but white has to
be really careful that he doesn't allow
the trade on black's terms because that
could be disastrous for white so magnus
has to be careful in the current
position
if we check out what ding's idea is he
simply wants to stop white from castling
and i mention this tension if white is a
bit careless and captures then
the black queen will step back and
suddenly it's against the rules to
castle through check so white can no
longer uh kind of have those castling
rights and it's not just that but the
black queen supports this key d3 square
the light square is really weak in
white's camp black is threatening to
jump in with a nasty night check hitting
the white king and hitting the white
rook uh also even hitting the white
bishop so um i think this would be
almost a losing mistake already for
magnus to trade off the bishops now he
has to wait for black to make that uh
exchange so for example if he castles uh
he still has to calculate what will
happen for example if the bishops come
off magnus has to take with the queen
now notice he can't take with the knight
because there's a pin on this diagonal
he has to stay with the queen and then
he has to work out the complications
here uh one other thing maybe magnus can
consider is moving the knight out the
way because there's just so much tension
and you've actually spotted something
yeah i mean i was thinking about moving
the knight out of the way but i i
couldn't see a grid square until i was
like okay maybe it can go to the edge of
the board or to protect the dark square
bishop it just has to move to protect
the dark square bishop because white
actually really wants to be in an
endgame because we've kind of discussed
in the past that uh in endgames if you
have a pawn weakness
then those pawn weaknesses are
vulnerable and the pawn that i'm
specifically talking about is that
pawn standing on c6 that's a backward
pawn that is got a target on his back
and look at it it's even got a rook
white rook looking at it so if white can
trade off pieces
especially queens then that is going to
be such a bad and he's done it he's
actually retweeted his night yes
basically the same idea just a safer
version he's dropped his knight back as
ivanka mentioned the key thing is to
defend this bishop because the queens
are about to come off suddenly this
tension has uh opened up on this
diagonal so black will most likely play
queen takes queen and after white
recaptures we see two things
one is ivanka's point that there's
actually an immediate attack against the
black knight and the pawn behind it but
also white delaying castling i was
really critical of that earlier but now
the point becomes clear because we're in
the end game suddenly the queens are off
and in end games kings are far better in
the center than on the side of the board
black's king is going to take an age to
come towards the center to actually help
support maybe these weak black pawns for
example but white's king is ready so if
everything disappears the rooks the
knights the bishops then white's king
far better placed than its counterpart
so really sneaky from magnus i wouldn't
have even looked that far ahead it just
looked too dangerous to me
but now he wants to have his king in the
center and because of this attack i
think black will jump in with a check uh
hitting the white king the white king
might indeed just slide back but
suddenly tension between all the bishops
there's a trade here coming there's a
trade here coming and for example if
everything comes off
in this type of order then it's ivanka's
point again it's all about this weak
pawn black has the weaknesses white has
the better king and therefore white has
a small advantage it's going to be quite
one-sided also magnus loving those end
games in general i think he'd be happy
to reach this type of position if
everything gets traded and the queens
have just come off the board so we might
be headed in this direction this is the
current position and these bishops are
about to disappear they're all going to
get traded off and white having the
better king having the better rooks
looking good so okay as expected again a
check and the king slides back
still very tense and magnus though i
think it's gone in his favor slightly
yeah i think magnus will be in his
element here and uh
yesterday you know we were asked about
what particular opening is magnus's
kryptonite
and uh
interestingly enough i found out today
that on chess 24 there's actually a
video series by ivan salgado lopez
spanish grand master he talks about
playing like magnus
and he uses he studies all his rapid
games but there is a chapter saying how
to beat magnus magnus
and i thought i should tell everyone
that this is probably must-see viewing
for everyone who wants to know
and according to ivan uh he says that
magnus master trades he knows how to
change those pieces and uh transfer his
advantages in from dynamic into
something concrete so basically don't go
for the trades
yeah i mean or just keep all the pieces
on the board and give lots of options to
trade
yeah and i've found well i mean i
haven't been successful necessarily
against magnus but uh just from studying
his games i've found yeah being quite
direct against him makes him
uncomfortable he wants to have tension
he wants to have lots of peace on the
board to know to kind of have the option
of trading this one trading that one but
if you're really direct
if you're going to force him to play
only moves every time he can get a bit
frustrated and uh it doesn't allow him
to kind of put his own personal kind of
stamp on the game uh so this opening i
think was a good choice from thing very
direct white didn't have many options
but
maybe just one slip actually black light
squared bishop coming out has allowed
magnus to initiate the queen trade
getting bishops off the board
so you've got to be really careful you
could be direct but not let magnus uh
kind of go for that kind of stylistic uh
stylistic preferences that he prefer
that he really likes so interesting yeah
black's rook meanwhile coming across
defending the weak pawn that yolanka
highlighted and now those dark square
bishops are about to leave the board as
well
all white needs to do is activate his
knight again the white knight at the
bottom of the board and i think he has a
very good position and uh the other
thing we talk about porn islands the
reason white has a long-term advantage
is because white has two porn islands
one island on the right half of the
board those four pawns connecting and
defending each other and one island on
the left side those two white pawns also
connecting each other black has an
isolated pawn on the a7 square two kind
of hanging pawns kind of and the center
of the board and then another island
over there near his king so it's better
to have as few porn islands as possible
so here magnus definitely with the
better pawn structure and the bishops
did leave the board as expected all
right well we did
talk a little bit about already the
candidates tournament ding's chances to
actually play in the candidates to have
a chance to qualify for the next world
championship match
he uh wasn't able to travel to the grand
prix because of covet regulations so
that means he was initially out of
contention to play in the candidates
then karjakin
has received his six months banned and
now we're trying to figure out who's
going to get karjakin's place this move
first of all yeah it's committal this is
actually what we call the hanging pawn
structure for black these two pawns side
by side in the center both on open files
but uh magnus now will try and attack
these pawns it's committal budding we'll
see how the next few moves progress yeah
wow so
feeder has announced that it is
the highest rated players on the mail
lists that will receive that final spot
currently that is dingley ran but people
are always talking about you have to
play some sort of 25 games what is this
rule i think you have to play 30 games
the last year yeah within the last 12
months just to prove you're an active
player for example otherwise gary
kasparov who's been retired since 2005
could claim oh i'm the highest rated
player uh but he's inactive he hasn't
played at all and ding actually over the
last 12 months has only played four
games wow so uh four out of 30 he still
needs to play 26 games by may which is
not easy yeah but then
our chess 24 colleague leon has informed
me sending me a link saying that the
chinese chess association will start a
series of qualification tournaments for
the 1919th asian games at the end of
this month all top players are required
to play including daily wren so that's
actually gonna probably give him a
chance
coincidence yeah what a currency yeah
no i i mean it's what his federation
needed to do especially in light of all
the
travel uh restrictions these days you
know the reason why
ding didn't play the candidate um not
the candidates the grand prix events is
because he just couldn't he couldn't
physically travel he couldn't leave the
country and uh well the chinese
federation have stepped up and they're
saying yep we will provide the
tournament so yeah good on them i say
yeah yeah i mean unfortunately he
couldn't play the grand uh the grand
swiss the grand prix he would have had
great chances in both of those
tournaments uh just because he is so
strong so it does make sense that he is
given a path and it's not actually going
to be easy anyway
does it have to be um it has to be
classical so long games 26 games and
it's not just that but he has to
maintain his rating if he loses a few
points aronian for example uh playing
the grand prix right now could overtake
him wesley so could overtake him he has
to play really well in those 26 games so
it's going to be difficult for ding
either way
and if lebaneronian though doesn't
qualify from the grand prix it's looking
good for him so far i i know he's in the
lead in his group um right now so he
could qualify that way as well yeah i
imagine i mean there's just too many
good players out there these days and
the candidates only eight spots it's uh
yeah it's hard to hard to claim one of
them yeah
all right well we are hoping to see
dingley ryan he is world number three uh
he deserves to get a chance to play in
the candidates one of the players magnus
carlson definitely respects the most and
we have some moves we have some moves
and unless i'm mistaken it looks like
magnus is about to win a pawn
and if you look at all the rooks they're
all stacked up on this c file but
black's pawn in the center which has
just continued advancing it is pinned so
white's knight now is going to jump out
the way to attack this pawn and that
pawn long term is going to drop it's
just an intruder it's too far into
white's territory i don't think black is
going to keep that pawn alive too much
longer
so white tonight i'm expecting maybe to
go back to the side of the board just to
attack it and
it's going to be hard for ding to kind
of keep coordination i think he's got an
idea in mind to sacrifice even another
pawn his central pawn the black d pawn
and uh yeah either way magnus is going
to win a pawn ding just has to go as
active as possible and look at this he
does indeed throw this pawn down the
board as well because if it's captured
at least the black knight can find an
outpost on the square this pawn
previously sat on
this one's really heating up it feels
like magnus if he's accurate
should be winning maybe should at least
win a pawn and still very healthy
position but thing trying to make it
difficult for him yeah ding definitely
uh living up to his name as a dynamic
player because i think this was the only
solution you know the only way to
maintain that pawn
so pawn takes porn like you say probably
going to be played and
knight parking itself in the middle of
the board
it's still not an easy position actually
because this night is going to be all
powerful i mean it can uh
it can even jump to give check you know
right time at the right time it might
jump to attack the white rook
so it seems to be that there's a
kind of standoff happening there wow i'm
really surprised magnus didn't take what
looked to be just a free pawn up for
grabs it looked like a gift from ding
but maybe he was just too scared of the
power of this knight
and instead magnus really surprisingly
just moved his rook across and after a
capture hit wow magnus not even taking
this pawn back so instead of being one
point up
for free he's now one pawn down magnus
and look at these two black pawns
they're super scary but magnus is
banking on the fact that he's going to
pick both of them off
very shortly he's going to try and lift
his rook up the board to the center and
just capture this pawn or maybe even the
pawn next to it and yeah suddenly the
whole reason actually behind magnus's
idea is that the black knight has lost
its access to this central square the
white rook doing a great job cutting
across the board uh keeping black's
pieces from entering the open file david
i feel like creative i feel like we need
one of those action replays but we have
to just take it back so that we can all
memorize this maneuver that
magnus played so you know instead of
taking the pawn he moved his rook to the
side controlling that pawn threatening
to take it with a rook so you have to
you have to capture the pawn and instead
of capturing he's like no let me just
push that pawn forward let me control
the night circuit and i will win those
two weak forms on the third row at my
leisure
white's just going to slide his rook up
and he's going to pick them both off and
it's just about domination of pieces and
wow i mean this is almost another level
another world because it's just about
this black knight we talked about how
strong it would be in the center now it
lacks any good squares
it's just completely controlled by
firstly this pawn also as mentioned this
rook so yeah magnus just really really
just killing ding's dreams there with
this last blow so would you say most
players would have just taken those
pawns yeah i mean in this position i
think i would have captured this without
thinking too long um and it's not just
that but in this position as well oh
sorry after the white rook slid across
it's just so tempting you can take this
pawn with your king maybe the king would
be a bit vulnerable or you can take with
your pawn but then you would have an
isolated pawn in the center and you do
allow black's knight to hop into the
middle so it's just about i mean that
sensitivity to your opponent's pieces
and this position
i mean at first it looks visually quite
good for black just because these two
pawns are so strong but
the longer you think the look the deeper
you look you realize black has no active
ideas the black rooks tied down actually
to this pawn and uh yeah these guys are
both going to drop off in the near
future whites are pawn down but
within the next five six moves he might
be pulling up
wow yeah uh very impressive by magnus
and it's a very vital pawn as well
because it's a past pawn there on the
left it's got no challenger and uh yeah
whilst we're waiting for ding to ponder
over his position and come up with an
answer well i have a few selfies and uh
to share with you and marco franz saying
knights will always be decisive and uh
he's right in this particular position
knights are awesome beasts
and
is sending us greetings as well from
croatia
wow hi croissant yeah definitely and
nick alexan is sending us greetings from
chicago i love this you know all around
the world and uh thank you very much for
your nice comments and then we have a
tweet from ren primary school and uh ren
chess champions well done to our
wonderful chess players on all they have
achieved badges and trophies all around
oh cool that's so sweet congratulations
definitely and meanwhile we have some
moves yeah so black's knight it felt
powerless it couldn't go towards the
center of the board where it wants to be
so black's knight's actually gone off to
the edge now but white as expected did
capture one of the pawns
one of black's extra pawns dropping off
and this last move from ding
multi-purpose black's pawn coming down
giving the black king some breathing
space so there's no background
checkmates against the black uh the
black monarch anymore and white just
pushing a pawn it's all about domination
of that black knight and magnus is
stopping that knight hopping back
towards the center
again instructive stuff i recommend
anyone out there to go and study these
last few moves and just look at that
black knight it's uh it's just powerless
white tonight also on the edge of the
board but it has a clear target black
far advanced pawn is about to fall
and i think there's just no saving it
nobody has to just hope somehow to find
counter play and the next three moves
four moves are really essential if black
just loses his pawn for nothing magnus
is gonna win uh ding needs to find some
magic but he's only got one minute so
in practical terms it looks i don't
wanna say lost for black but really
really difficult already yeah i'm gonna
say lost for black
not just because of the time deficit but
also because when i compare all the
pieces and maybe the potential traits
and the position of the kings i'm like
okay white is primed and ready to go for
all the pieces coming off the board
black
not so much bad nights bad king
thing looks uncomfortable as well you're
going to be torn down
and uh yeah now his knights come back
where it came from just a couple of
moves ago that's not a good sign losing
time for ding and yeah with less than
one minute here against five evaluation
bar as well it's going to start edging
up and up and up over the next few moves
uh magnus also has a clear plan here he
can step forward with that white rook at
the bottom of the board and start going
after black's c3 pawn it only has two
defenders soon there's gonna be three
pieces attacking it so it's gonna drop
off
and uh david k from the uk
just donated 21 to our fundraiser for
unicef we also saw pitt from sweden
donating jill from the us the whole
world is coming together and donating
money to this fundraiser all the money
goes to unicef who is doing
so important life-saving work for
the children who is affected and their
families by the war in ukraine so thank
you to everyone who is donating our goal
is 120 000 so we need to keep that money
coming thank you to everyone
and a couple of moves white as expected
did lift his rook up you've got to be
slightly careful now so black pushing a
pawn you don't really want to rush and
capture black's far advanced pawn on the
c3 square because there might be some
annoying night jumps black's knight
might then gain access to the center of
the board so you've got to be really
timely with any trades here for magnus
and
there are a few maybe tricks against the
white king as well we talked about kings
being great in the end game but you
don't want to walk into too much danger
the black rooks could slide across at
any moment and there we go i was about
to say white's king feeling a bit of
discomfort magnus has just slid it back
guiding it back to safety behind its own
pawns and if we see a trade of pawns in
front of the white king the white king
will happily step forward ding now
shaking his head 40 seconds
white is now finally threatening to
capture that annoying black pawn on c3
yeah
i love magnus's last move you know not
only tucking the king behind some pawn
shelter but also you know guarding the
king from any potential night checks
which is really really important
nights are crafty pieces you've got to
look out for the way that they move and
uh well now magnus will he rush to take
that pawn i think i would yeah he can
safely capture now on the c3 square you
don't want to capture with the white
knight if you bring back the white
knight then actually you walk into a pin
black's rooks are so strong so you want
to capture with one of the white rooks
and uh i guess you can force a trade of
at least one set of rooks if white
captures with the d-rook the rook on the
d-file and just capture across the board
and just kind of create that tension
between the four rooks again
okay he captures this way this is also
perfectly fine uh but it doesn't
necessarily force the rook trade yet and
therefore ding has a move to improve his
king
and uh okay magnus is a whole pawn up
that's why the evaluation bar says plus
one for white
still some work to be done to convert
this white's two versus one advantage on
the left side that will come into play
later uh but right now whiten maybe
needs to trade off a set of rooks
re-centralize the white knight and uh
yeah ding he needs to keep one set of
rooks alive at least yeah if all of the
rooks disappear white's simply going to
win if it's just knights and pawns on
the board there is uh one trap on the
board that i can see that magnus must be
very careful not to fall into and that
is uh if he
gets ambitious and maybe pushes his f
pawn forward or even takes the pawn
because uh there he could
he could he could struggle because
by pushing that pawn forward you lose
control over the e4 square
and suddenly something like that would
be on the board
yeah so it's all about keeping this pawn
on its square and not pushing it forward
or capturing you need to keep it here to
dominate the black knight just remember
this pattern everyone at home a pawn on
the third rank always dominate a knight
on the sixth rank if they're opposite
each other on the same file here so uh
yep this knight's still unable to jump
forward and magnus decides okay he's
only stronger on one side of the board
that's this left side of the board he's
got this two versus one advantage so why
not play on the side that you're
stronger very logical he pushes this
pawn forward that being said the point
is undefended temporarily so maybe some
tricks in the air for black and okay
talking of tricks he does bring his rook
down
maybe keeping an eye on this pawn you're
not actually threatening it right now
for example if white moves the king
you're not threatening this pawn because
your rook would fall at the top of the
board but ding trying his best to just
put pieces in the white half just annoy
magnus as much as possible with some
vague hints of threats and uh three
minutes left for magnus 14 seconds left
for ding what do you think what will be
the result in this game
should be a magnus win unless he gets
nervous or less he rushes it a bit too
much i mean ding's got a different
difficult position in general but the
clock situation as well does not help
him
i mean imagine a situation where he
maybe has one move to save the game or
two moves to save the game he's only got
five seconds
it's going to be hard for him
but he is looking focused yeah and he's
played okay the last few moves to make
it at least difficult tricky for magnus
to
kind of secure and uh
just drive home
i have to say i quite like this last
move these last few moves that ding has
played i feel that okay maybe the
computer doesn't like them but i feel on
a practical level they're maximizing
black's chances and pawn takes pawn so
now suddenly the knight sitting on f6
has a few squares to look at and also
the rook on the fourth row can
maybe start threatening some kind of
tricks by pushing the a pawn up a few
squares
and uh destabilizing white's born
majority there i completely agree i
think ding's doing everything he can to
make life as difficult as possible for
magnus look at this black knight now
it's hitting the white pawn on the h2
square that's undefended it would fall
the check but he also wants to retreat
the black knight into the center of the
board to the e5 square actually that
would be a fork as well hitting the
white king hitting the white rooks and
this is one thing you never want you wow
okay magnus there allowing a fork but i
was gonna say you never want your king
and rooks too near each other when
there's an enemy knight nearby the
knight is gonna threaten all sorts of
forks but now if the black knight does
hop into the center of the board with a
check the white king will just move and
because white is actually threatening
black's rook on the fourth rank there's
no time for black to win material so i
think magnus has calculated this really
really well it looks scary actually
magnus playing with fire a bit but uh
for now he's still in charge and ding
down to three seconds oh he did give a
check in the end white's king now it's
just going to retreat
it's just going to move yeah to a square
where it's not the king is safe and it
will not be checked so i mean i would
put it
you want to move towards your rook in
the center yes i feel that too
so maybe you could sidestep just one
square to this uh one square to the left
or you could slide back so what we're
expecting white's king to go to the left
two safe squares
and uh magnus just has to choose the
safest it's not clear which one
and okay three seconds three seconds i
know and uh i think he's starting to
feel the pressure actually you know he
he doesn't give much away but there you
kind of felt that he was
feeling the heat a little bit okay now
there's a serious threat on the board
white is threatening to jump in with a
knight and give a check a discover check
and win material and that's why ding
just moved his king forward yup so
black's king now not allowing any checks
really sensible again just another trick
to remember especially if
viewers at home are playing lots of
blitz chess bullet chess just put your
king on squares it cannot be checked by
the enemy knight
just so you don't have to calculate
anymore you don't have to waste time uh
worrying about forks or discovered
attacks and uh meanwhile the black king
continuing to advance it is an end game
after all and earlier i said white's
king was better than blacks now black's
king you can make an argument for it
being better than whites uh that being
said white is a pawn up still and full
control at the moment at least for
magnus and it's a battle of the kings
they're fearless going on adventures
both of them cool yeah okay the black
rook i was going to say has to do
something it was just staring at a
really strong white knight white's
knight on an outpost no point staring at
that piece you might as well switch
focus to stare down at the white king
and white's king now really has to move
you don't want to allow any discover
checks right
and it's tempting actually to move back
with the king
i would put it on the d2 square and try
to work the king round to the left in
order to assist
what's uh extra porn on the queen side
nice silvanka yeah yeah i was more
inclined to go to the other side but
then once you mention this plan of just
kind of switching the king's focus
helping
the king will act as a guardian a
shepherd for these two white pawns on
the left as soon as you mentioned that i
thought yeah that's the way forward the
white rook notice how it guards all the
pawns on the third rank white's rook is
actually as the best defensive piece
right now
it's just on a great square can't get
attacked by black's knight and guards
everything
and here we go white's king has started
its journey those white pawns the two
versus one advantage that's going to
decide this game and that's where magnus
is banking all of his hopes
and okay
ding trying to create something he's
actually giving up another pawn he's one
pawn down he's offering this pawn which
is captured it now at least black has a
past pawn of his own the black f pawn i
know it's stuck behind the black king
right now but at least it can run down
the ball later
and at least the black rook actually has
a job to do finally he starts to attack
some of white sports yeah this is a good
strategy as well because you know if
you're going to lose the game anyhow you
might as well seek complications and if
that
involves sacrificing material just to
get a past pawn then do it um i i
suspect that magnus will just continue
with his plan i think he wins the pawn
race i think he's very fast yeah there's
two i put there we go the pawn race has
been initiated and white is indeed very
fast those pawns already only three four
moves away from promoting to a new queen
black's f pawn meanwhile still
it's gonna take an age for that to start
moving
uh that being said ding has found a
really sneaky move and magnus just
making a bit of a gesture there the bar
goes down yeah look at the black rook
it's actually just completely
immobilizing white's two pawns those two
white pawns maybe he was a bit hasty
maybe he should have brought his king
forward uh white's king now cannot go
and support its pawns and those two
pawns together a bit loose they have to
stay defending each other the knight has
to stay defending them white is a bit
tied up oh magnus is gonna be furious
because look at him because yeah like
you say you know the root can't move
because if it moves the black rook will
come and give check to the white king
and attack the knight at the same time
the knight can't move
it needs to defend his pawn and uh none
of white's pawns can move you'll just
get captured so white's king is the only
piece by process of elimination that
could actually move in that last
position
without losing material and suddenly
suddenly black's rook is just the best
piece on the board and black's knight
centralized has its eyes on both sides
as well
ding wow
weaving his magic there i think magnus
probably would have just won very
quickly if he'd brought his king to help
his pawns but the white king now is
not in a good position it just goes to
show that even the world champion even
the engel maestro will make mistakes can
be careless by playing quickly and
not using basic principles if it stopped
and said teamwork dream work
you would for sure put the king there
and we've talked about that race that
white was winning i mean white was
winning by four or five moves he didn't
need to immediately push the pawns you
should have supported them first
and that race later uh would have been
very one-sided
but now suddenly look at this the black
king going after white's remaining pawn
on the right side and clearing the path
from black's f-pawn could ding win this
game
if white loses if magnus goes on tilt as
we say and kind of tries to push too
hard to win
i could imagine a scenario the thing is
magnus now has to take big risks in
order to promote well to push any one of
his pawns i don't say i see a clear way
how to do it so i suspect that
maybe
maybe he could even lose the thread and
like david says go on tilt and anything
can happen wow i've lost games like this
me too many times and uh we talk
sometimes in chess about two result
positions that means just five moves ago
magnus was playing for the win
very worst it would have been a draw now
this is a three result game again
because black he's one is pawn back it's
two pawns versus two pawns and black is
the only one with the past pawn right
now and magnus is down on the clock nine
seconds seven seconds five and okay and
he'll be feeling the pressure he has to
make a move he makes a rook move with
three seconds left on his clock that is
really brave walking into a night fork
black's knight can actually come and
check hitting the white king and hitting
the white rook but okay it does it looks
like white's about to lose a rook but he
can counter-attack against black's rook
there and magnus
really really brave move it looks okay
but both sides under 20 seconds can
there be moves like rook takes pawn yeah
can you play these kind of desperados
okay he's done it he's actually played
it and he can give up his rook black
because the white rook is under fire
from the black knight so rather than go
for a direct trade you might as well try
and grab a pawn in the process and
magnus look at him he is furious he's
about to be a pawn down
it should be a draw because everything's
just disappearing
but he needs to move that's right and
huge time trouble for both of them there
could definitely be some blunders here
definitely and magnus is i think he's
blunted a couple of times already uh
he's lucky he's not losing on the spot
but look at this magnus is going to have
to defend a difficult end game because
he's lost his knight
magnus has lost his knight but he will
be able to remove black's remaining pawn
from the position and he's so frustrated
oh i mean understandably now he's on the
defensive side he should have been
winning this game it should still be a
draw even if white loses his pawn
because rook and knight against a rook
is a very well known draw but magnus
still has to work for that half point
he's not winning this one anymore magnus
and ding has some hopes the momentum is
in his favor yes it should be a draw but
if your opponent psychologically is is
uh kind of angry or
uncomfortable then who knows the white
the black king now and knight moving
towards the white king and the other
match as well is kind of following this
uh
thread liam the bar has been over to his
side in that game now it's slightly over
to judah's side with the black pieces
interesting
yeah and
yeah i mean two fighting games no matter
what the results now uh in this first
round of semi-finals but white's pawn
running up the ward is still going to
take a while yeah
if you'd said to me like at the
beginning of this ending
black would be the one pushing for a win
i would say no
no no not one hope and anything but uh
yeah
here we are this is what goes to show
when you're a little bit careless and uh
you start to let your emotions dictate
your play
yeah and i mentioned just at the
beginning of today uh for ding a draw is
a good result in the first game magnus
now is going to be worried ding is
actually much more dangerous with white
than he is with black
so yeah a draw with black for ding would
be a fantastic result
white now just trying to harass the
black king is he going to keep checking
and secure the draw here magnus or does
ding have some way to play for the win
maybe ding will just get out this game
and think okay it's been a draw but no
he plays for the win he doesn't want to
repeat the position and now he's
attacking white's remaining pawn with
the black rook is that paul gonna fall
white's king now checked away from the
defense of its pawn
you've got to be actually a bit careful
here with white you go to the side of
the board
very logical but there are some ideas of
checkmating this white king
so yeah magnus has to be really careful
there's a checkmate threat on the board
the black knight couldn't have been
captured black would have slit his rook
across and trapped the white king so the
white rook doing some work to drive the
black king away this time
but
we might see a scenario where black
takes the next 10 15 moves to round up
white pawn and then plays for 50 moves
to try and deliver checkmate but uh
either way that white pawn
it's all about whether it can survive if
it can magnus will easily seal the draw
if it doesn't ding can play for the win
in peace
okay uh here we go magnus trying to
trade the rooks if the rooks come off
it's an immediate draw i think he's
going to secure it and look at that
young christophe duda has won the first
game against liam le with the black
pieces something must have happened in
that game as well some drama and a great
win for duda liam now has to make a
comeback
wow and some i just peeked over and it's
some real symmetry that game was
actually the exact same end game as this
one except
the side with the knight had two pawns
so
so in that one it was also rook knight
and some pawns on the board
interesting really interesting it's rare
to see two games kind of mirror each
other like that and with the same
storyline similar storyline as well turn
around gosh yeah i mean that's how tense
these uh semi-finals are with such
strong players uh just really just
eeking out those small
kind of end game advantages and look at
this little black knight is completely
stuck in the corner
i don't know if we have a rhyme for
knights in the corner but they are
terrible pieces but at least the white
pawn is also
stuck at the moment the thing is though
um the plan for magnus is pretty simple
he just has to keep guarding that pawn
and
unfortunately there's really no way for
black to even win that pawn without
initiating a work trade yeah it's going
gonna be very very hard for white to
pick off that pawn i do see maybe one
way but it takes a long time and black's
king will have to contort itself to stay
on the edge of the board and you're the
specialist on uh move 50 50 overall
we have just seen a pawn push however
white's pawn just going to the seventh
rank a few moves ago
i wonder will we hit move 100 in the
first game of today ah
and
already here we go black's king replaces
the knight as the defender and now here
we go black's knight about to pick off
the pawn 50 moves just starts now if we
reach move 100 and i think 28 then the
game will be a draw magnus needs to
defend till then ding needs to checkmate
or win the white rook before move 100
and sorry 27. so okay yeah it's
it's countdown time but okay how hard is
that with only a rook and a night it's
impossible to win with best play okay
white should be able to draw this the
problem is there's no way to force
white's king to the edge of the board
and keep your king opposite the
opponent's king to kind of close the
mating that white's rook is always going
to deliver some annoying checks and
drive the black king away and uh it's
not just the checks but the white rook
will also pin the black knight
just to stop black utilizing and
combining his pieces
with that teamwork that we always talk
about yeah and this one is also quite
good for the defender because the king
is in the middle of the board okay when
the king starts off in the corner of the
board or the edge then it becomes a
little bit more complicated because of
mating nets here white king safe as
houses yeah there have been some famous
examples of the
kind of attacking side the side with the
extra knight winning this end game gary
kasparov wants to beat judith polgar in
this exact end game
but
with perfect defense it's a draw hand uh
i've actually defended it a few times
myself including against liam who's
playing in the other semi-final ah
so yeah it should be a draw but
but do you think ding will keep playing
i think he should for as long as
possible why not there's no risk for
black even if black loses his rook it
should still technically be a draw a
rook against the knight
so uh yeah no risk at all here for ding
you might as well play as long as you
can just show your opponent whose boss
force them to suffer and defend
and uh okay slowly but surely the white
king's being driven back down towards
the first rank
can didn't continue this pattern
it's not going to be easy to
kind of
close the box around the king because
white's rook now notice how it's going
up and behind the black king and it's
going to start delivering those annoying
checks yeah
yeah it's really important in games
especially rook endings to remember this
technique of checking from the side
checking from behind and checking from
in front now they're not all the same
checking form in front is actually worst
form of check you want to be checking
from behind and then the side just
remember those two techniques yeah
that's right and uh yeah just pin the
knight if in doubt pin your opponent's
night here black's knight unable to kind
of hop towards the white king and as
soon as the pin is broken as soon as the
black king moves either side we'll see a
check
or the white king can step up but later
on magnus depending on where the black
king goes he'll try and dodge so if the
black king goes to the left he'll go to
the right if the black king goes to the
right he'll go to the left and uh yeah
it's just
classic strategy and look how much time
they've built up on the clock both sides
were under 10 seconds a moment ago now
they're around four minutes
wow well dingley ren is definitely
thinking trying to figure out i mean
if they they only had 10 seconds left on
the clock then i would think there would
be big chances for ding it depends if
they go at a time i would say no
um because that like if you know the
technique of just checking from behind
checking from the side pinning the
knight
then you're should you should be good
okay um
this so it's a little bit like automatic
for grand masters to find those right
moves yeah
i mean
the knight is quite a short-range piece
this is the big issue it's kind of like
the bishop where the bishop actually is
much harder to defend against because
the bishop can obstructs the rook but at
the same time control some critical
checking squares so if it was a rook and
a bishop
that's it they're with some serious
winning chances still a draw with best
player but very difficult to defend him
yeah we saw hans niemann lose that for
example in the prelims in the final game
and he hasn't been the only one we've
also saw vidit lucid as well
back in the first season of the tour and
vincent kaimer as well
last month so
uh yeah right now i actually saw ding
something flash up i think he minimized
the board just to kind of maybe check
magnus's camera but also to count the
number of moves that you notice they
both paused i think ding just from his
body language he was counting when the
last capture was so he would figure out
exactly how many more moves he could try
to win this game
it's a really interesting moment there
but uh i think he counted he realized
that the last capture was on move 77 for
black
so 50 move rule if there are no captures
or pawn pushes it's a draw
127. that's what we're looking for to
make the countdown still a while to go
but uh
magnus knows the draw is within his
grasp again creating this pin on the
black knight
unfortunately just no way forward these
two definitely telling us that they're
gonna give us a fighting match the
position and the opening looked like
something that could be a quick draw we
did see that yesterday but here we are
they played for 57 minutes definitely
not a quick draw and with 100 100 yay
not often i i see you move 100 but it
seems to be quite a regular for you
yeah i mean this is my favorite kind of
game who who wants to win in 10 moves
15 moves
i mean i'm that's your party trick
exactly i'm hoping that i'll be inspired
by this game to last as long as possible
against magnus age 10 on the app yes
because 100 moves would be a lot of
money for traffic oh that would be
amazing
and one thing that really impresses me
about david is that um he can play 400
moves and you know he's he's always said
in the past that he likes to play when
he's a bit hungry because that makes him
really hungry so you must be famished by
the time you finish that game but how do
you keep your energy going you know and
i struggle these days but when i was
younger i would often maybe okay i'd
have like a bowl of cereal for breakfast
and then i wouldn't eat until the game
finishes at eight nine pm so i don't
know i just and then i would eat like a
king i'd have a feast yeah but uh yeah i
don't recommend it it's uh i think these
top players the top players for a reason
snacking up as we often see in is ding
abandoning his winning chances
it looks like the game has finally been
drawn on move 110.